so what exactly is the future outlook of
bitcoin we don't know nobody knows what
the future holds but what we can do is
we can look at the on-chain metrics and
we can go ahead and determine what is
likely to happen based on what those
on-chain metrics are saying so if we
first go to the young wizard will
clemente he posted a chart yesterday i
believe it was where he said 93 of
bitcoin supply has not moved in a month
think about that 93
of bitcoin has not moved in a month the
strong hands are here to stay i believe
this is an all-time high 93
of the total circulating supply of
bitcoin has not moved in 30 days if you
want to see an asset that is held by
illiquid hands by strong hands by
long-term holders whatever you want to
call them
diamond hands
and demand increases the price has to go
up because 93 percent of the circulating
supply of bitcoin is not moving in over
a month now on top of that dylan leclair
over at bitcoin magazine another
on-chain analyst he published two
article uh two photos or charts or
tables or whatever the hell you want to
call these the first is the bitcoin
supply held by long-term holders
continues to break all-time highs the
way to think about this is as the price
goes up
the long-term holders sell into the bull
market so as you can see here be between
what is essentially october november of
2019 the long-term holders continued to
drive higher and higher that's the
orange going from the left of the chart
all the way up to that peak there we
peaked somewhere around september or
october of 2020 that's when the price
really started to move and so that price
movement from somewhere in the 11 000 uh
or i'm sorry somewhere in like the 10 11
000 range all the way up to 60 000 we
went from very high percentage of
long-term holders to a very low
percentage of long-term holders why the
long-term holders were selling into the
bull market so where are we now if you
look starting in may of 2021 a couple of
months ago
we started to see a huge recovery in the
percent of long-term holders we are now
at an all-time high never before have
more people with long-term tendencies
held bitcoin more bitcoin is held by
those long-term holders than ever before
what does that mean as you can see again
in the past just as uh as early as uh
2019 or last year
as that number increases it usually
leads to a future significant price
increase the history is not an indicator
of future performance but we can use it
usually history rhymes and so to see 93
of bitcoin not moving in a month and the
percent of the bitcoin supply held by
long-term holders at an all-time high it
typically is quite bullish then if we
move on and we look at the bitcoin
balance on exchanges dylan posted and
said it continues to make new lows what
does that mean
well as you can see here that gold line
is
falling aggressively that means that
people have gone on to an exchange
they've bought bitcoin and then they
take the bitcoin off the exchange why is
that important because as you can see as
more and more bitcoin comes off the
exchanges the price tends to work
inversely bitcoin comes off exchanges so
the supply balance on exchanges drops
price goes up why because there's less
bitcoin on the exchange that can be sold
there's less cell pressure there's more
holding of the asset and so whether we
are looking at those huddle waves with
93 of bitcoin supply haven't moved in a
month whether it is the supply of
bitcoin held by long-term holders at an
all-time high or we are looking at the
balance exchanges making new lows
every single data point when you look at
the supply of bitcoin continues to tell
a story of a potential bitcoin supply
shock doesn't mean it's going to happen
there's obviously risk you should do
your own research but it does mean that
if the on-chain metrics are confirmed
with future price movements that would
likely lead to a very significant price
increase and so this is the beauty of
the bitcoin network is we get to see all
of this information in the stock market
it would be very hard to pull this on a
consistent basis you can look at the
quarterly filings you can see who's
buying or who's selling that's publicly
traded but you couldn't see all of the
entities here not only can you see all
of the entities and where the bitcoin is
going on the bitcoin blockchain in a
transparent ledger but you also get near
real-time access to that information you
don't just get it quarterly you get it
on a very consistent basis and so we can
see things like day-to-day movements of
the supply whether that's on exchanges
in short-term holders hands or long-term
holders and so to me this is part of the
beauty of this asset is that we get to
understand who's doing what with bitcoin
and overwhelmingly every data point is
telling us people are going onto
exchanges they're buying bitcoin they're
taking it off the exchanges and they are
holding it in long-term hands and they
are not bringing it back to exchanges 93
of bitcoin supply hasn't moved in a
month i like
where i think we are headed supply
squeeze incoming
we should get like a horn or something
or like an alarm so that when it happens
we just say like told you like supply
squeeze
and we could just hit it so that
everyone knows told you so what do you
think john
yeah long-term holders are extremely
important to kind of little uh to add
validity to the store value uh can we
bring back up that chart about um
the uh
the long-term holders the supply held by
long-term holders uh yeah that one so
i'm curious what you guys think about
this like it seems when the supply that
was actually held by long-term holders
uh was significantly down that's when
the price was the highest it was is that
because a bunch of retail traders or was
there i think there's a lot in the price
and that's why once that went back down
it's because everyone's selling into it
so the way that the long-term holders
and kind of the whales folks who've been
around a long time essentially what'll
happen is there's a bunch of
accumulation remember back in june july
for those that have watched the show uh
or listen to the podcast we talked a lot
about accumulation phase and so what was
happening was you can look on this chart
here so again go back to like late 2019
october november you can see with the uh
price movement it basically was sideways
all the way until september october of
2020. so from late 2019 for a year to
2020 price just went sideways and so
what was happening was you can see in
orange there was just pure accumulation
the long-term holders kept buying up
more and more bitcoin also people the
long-term holder uh kind of benchmark is
usually 155 days that's what they
determine if you've only held the
bitcoin for less than 155 days you're
considered a short-term holder once you
cross 155 usually that's determined
long-term holder and so in that time
period there's some new people who came
in and bought bitcoin they were
short-term holder but eventually 155
days expires and they become long-term
holders so whether you were already a
long-term holder buying new bitcoin or
you were new and then you kind of cross
over into the long-term holder box you
can see there's pure accumulation that
thing is just going up up up up
as more and more demand came in in
september october november then we saw
that price explode upwards and so when
that price goes up there's profit taking
so what do people do you can see all
those long-term holders start selling
into the bull market and so the way that
you can usually tell that you're at or
near a top in the price is to look and
see well how much of the long-term
holders have sold there's no way that
we're at a top right kind of an air
quotes of price because we're at an
all-time high of long-term holders every
single cycle we've ever seen with this
asset long-term holders are selling into
the bull market they're not accumulating
bitcoin in the tops of the bull market
and so that dip in the orange there is
showing the long-term holders at the
highest prices they basically sold
everything at those high prices then
they started to buy it back as that
price kind of started fell down and went
sideways there around thirty thousand
thirty five thousand and so now all of a
sudden we've come roaring back long-term
holders are holding all this bitcoin
we're at an all-time high what that
likely is gonna see again is at some
point we'll get a massive move upwards
in price uh and then you'll see the same
thing as the long-term holders will sell
into uh in a profitable manner into the
market and we'll see kind of a dip in
long-term holders they'll re-accumulate
we'll play the game over and over and
over again but this is how markets work
and it just so happens when you have a
finite asset it's super clear
because
there's almost so much in circulation
there's no way it's not like a
corporation where they could come in and
they could issue more stock or they
could do things to change the supply the
supply is fixed we know it's 100
certainty what the supply currently is
and we know what the incoming daily
supply is and so if in a supply demand
equation if supply is certain and known
then you only have to extrapolate out
what the demand is and we can see that
demand continues to increase and so if
you just continue to extrapolate this
out you can quickly see hey price is
likely not to be at you know 45 000 at
the end of the year yeah look the the
the nature of the constrained and
programmatic schedule of supply within
bitcoin is beautiful because you can do
things like this where you can look at
just the demand side and you can see uh
that we're nowhere near the top of this
bull run yet because of these metrics
right these on-chain metrics showing us
uh where the long-term holders are and
where they're seeing that value so i
mean we don't get financial advice on
the show but i'm putting my seat belt on
exactly that's exactly what we're gonna
do what's up guys bang bang thanks so
much for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]
you